[Music]
[Music]
my talk is flapping birds and space
telescopes and you would think that
should have nothing to do with one
another but i hope by the end of these
18 minutes you'll see a little bit of a
relation it ties to origami so let me
start what is origami
most people think they know what origami
is it's this flapping birds toys cootie
catchers that sort of thing and that is
what origami used to be
but it's become something else it's
become an art form a form of sculpture
the common theme what makes it origami
is folding is how we create the form
now it's very old this is a plate from
1797 shows these women playing with
these toys if you look close it's this
shape called a crane every japanese kid
learns how to fold that crane so this
art has been around for hundreds of
years and you would think something
that's been around that long so
restrictive folding only everything that
could be done has been done a long time
ago and that might have been the case
but in the 20th century a japanese
folder named yoshizawa came along and he
created tens of thousands of new designs
but even more importantly he created a
language a way we could communicate a
code of dots dashes and arrows
hearkening back to susan blackmore's
talk we now have a means of transmitting
information with heredity and selection
and we know where that leads
and where it has led in origami is to
things like this
this is an origami figure
one sheet no cuts folding only
hundreds of folds
this too is origami and this shows where
we've gone in the modern world
naturalism detail you can get horns
antlers even if you look close cloven
hooves and it raises a question what
changed what and what changed is
something you might not have expected in
an art which is
math that is people applied mathematical
principles to uh
to to the art to discover the underlying
laws and that leads to a very
powerful tool the secret to productivity
in so many fields and in origami
is letting dead people do your work for
you
because what you can do is
take your problem and turn it into a
problem that someone else's has solved
and used their solutions
and i want to tell you how we did that
in origami
origami revolves around crease patterns
the crease pattern shown here is the
underlying blueprint for an origami
figure and you can't just draw them
arbitrarily they have to obey four
simple laws and they're very simple easy
to understand the first law is to color
ability you can color any crease pattern
with just two colors without ever having
the same color
meeting the directions of the folds at
any vertex the number of mountain folds
the number of valley folds always
differs by two two more or two less
nothing else
if you look at the angles around the
fold you find that if you number the
angles in a circle all the even numbered
angles add up to a straight line all the
odd numbered angles add up to a straight
line and if you look at how the layers
stack you'll find that no matter how you
stack folds and sheets a sheet can never
penetrate a fold so that's four simple
laws that's all you need in origami all
of origami comes from that and you think
can four simple laws give rise to that
kind of complexity but indeed the laws
of quantum mechanics can be written down
on a napkin and yet they govern all of
chemistry all of life all of history
if we obey these laws we can do amazing
things
so in origami to obey these laws we can
take simple patterns like this repeating
pattern of folds called textures and by
itself it's nothing but if we follow the
laws of origami we can put these
patterns into another fold that itself
might be something very very simple but
when we put it together we get something
a little different
this fish
400 scales again it is one uncut square
only folding
and if you don't want to fold 400 scales
you can back off and just do a few
things and add plates to the back of a
turtle or toes or you can ramp up and go
up to 50 stars on a flag with 13 stripes
and if you want to go really crazy a
thousand scales on a rattlesnake and
this guy's on display downstairs so take
a look if you get a chance
the most powerful tools in origami have
related to how we get parts of creatures
and i can put it in this simple equation
we take an idea
combine it with a square
and you get an origami figure
[Music]
what matters is what we mean by those
symbols and you might say can you really
be that specific i mean a stag beetle
it's got two points for jaws it's got
antennae can you be that specific in the
detail and yeah you really can
so how do we do that well we break it
down into a few smaller steps so let me
stretch out that equation i start with
my idea i abstract it what's the most
abstract form it's a stick figure
and from that stick figure i somehow
have to get to a folded shape that has a
part for every bit of the subject the
flap for every leg and then once i have
that folded shape that we call the base
you can make the legs narrower you can
bend them you can turn it into the
finished shape now the first step pretty
easy take an idea draw a stick figure
the last step is not so hard but that
middle step going from the abstract
description to the folded shape that's
hard
but that's the place where the
mathematical ideas can get us over the
hump i'm going to show you all how to do
that so you can go go out of here and
fold something but we're going to start
small this base has a lot of flaps in it
we're going to learn how to make one
flap
how would you make a single flap
take a square fold it in half fold it in
half fold it again until it gets long
and narrow
and then we'll say the end of that
that's a flap i could use that for a leg
and arm anything like that
what paper went into that flap well if i
unfold it and go back to the crease
pattern you can see that the upper left
corner of that shape is the paper that
went into the flap so that's the flap
and all the rest of the paper is left
over i can use it for something else
well there's other ways of making a flap
there's other dimensions for flaps if i
make the flaps skinnier i can use a bit
less paper if i make the flap as
skinny as possible i get to the limit of
the minimum amount of paper needed and
you can see there it needs a quarter
circle of paper to make a flap
there's other ways of making a flaps if
i put the flap on the edge it uses a
half circle of paper and if i make the
flap from the middle it uses a full
circle so no matter how i make a flap it
needs some part of a circular region of
paper
so now we're ready to scale up what if i
want to make something that has a lot of
flaps what do i need
i need a lot of circles
and in the 1990s origami artists
discovered these principles and realized
we could make arbitrarily complicated
figures just by packing circles
and here's where the dead people start
to help us out
because lots of people have this have
studied the problem of packing circles i
can rely on that vast history of
mathematicians and artists looking at
disk packings and arrangements and i can
use those patterns now to create origami
shapes so we figured out these rules
whereby you pack circles you you
decorate the patterns of circles with
lines according to more rules that gives
you the folds those folds fold into a
base you shape the base
you get a folded shape in this case a
cockroach and it's so simple
it's so simple that a computer could do
it
and you say well you know how simple is
that but computers you need to be able
to describe things in very basic terms
and with this we could so i wrote a
computer program a bunch of years ago
called tree maker and you can download
it from my website it's free runs on all
the major platforms even windows
and you just draw a stick figure and it
calculates the crease pattern it does
the circle packing calculates the crease
pattern and if you use that stick figure
that i just showed which you can kind of
tell it's a deer it's got an antlers
you'll get this crease pattern and if
you take this crease pattern you fold on
the dotted lines you'll get a base that
you can then shape
into a deer
with exactly the crease pattern that you
wanted
and if you want a different deer it's
not a white tail deer but you want a
mule deer or an elk you change the
packing and you can do an elk
or you could do a moose or really any
other kind of deer these techniques
revolutionized this art we found we
could do insects spiders which are close
things with legs things with
legs and wings things with legs an
antenna and if folding a single praying
mantis from a single uncut square wasn't
interesting enough then you could do two
praying mantises from a single uncut
square
she's eating him
i call it snack time
and and you can do more than just
insects this uh you can you can put
details toes and claws grizzly bear has
claws this tree frog has toes actually
lots of people in origami now put toes
into their models toes have become an
origami meme because everyone's doing it
you can you can make multiple subjects
so these are a couple of
instrumentalists the guitar player
from a single square the bass player
from a single square and if you say well
but guitar bass that's not so hot do a
little more complicated instrument well
then you could do an organ
and what this is allowed
is the creation of origami on demand so
so now people can say i want exactly
this and this and this and you can go
out and fold it and sometimes you create
high art and sometimes you pay the bills
by doing some commercial work but i want
to show you some examples everything
you'll see here
except the car
is origami
[Music]
mitsubishi endeavor with a powerful 3.8
liter v6 and available all-wheel drive a
mythic combination of beauty and beast
mitsubishi driven to thrill
just to show you this really was
folded paper computers made things move
but these were all real folded objects
that we made
and we can use this not just for visuals
but it turns out to be useful even in
the real world surprisingly origami and
the structures that we've developed in
origami turn out to have applications in
medicine and science in space in the
body consumer electronics and more and i
want to show you some of these examples
one of the earliest was this pattern
this folded pattern
studied by coryo miura japanese engineer
studied a folding pattern realized this
could fold down into an extremely
compact package that had a very simple
opening and closing structure and he
used it to design this solar array it's
an artist rendition but it flew in a
japanese telescope in 1995.
now there is actually a little origami
in the james webb space telescope but
it's very simple the telescope
is going up in space it unfolds in two
places it folds in thirds it's a very
simple pattern you wouldn't even call
that origami they certainly didn't need
to talk to origami artists but if you
want to go higher and go larger than
this then you might need some origami
engineers at lawrence livermore national
lab had an idea for a telescope much
larger they called it the eyeglass the
design called for geosynchronous orbit
25 000 miles up 100 meter diameter lens
so imagine a lens the size of a football
field there were two groups of people
who were interested in this planetary
scientists who want to look up
and then other people who who wanted to
look down
but whether you look up or look down how
do you get it up in space you've got to
get it up there in a rocket and rockets
are small so you have to make it smaller
how do you make a large sheet of glass
smaller
well about the only way is to fold it up
somehow so you have to do something like
this this was a
small model folded lens you divide up
the panels you add flexures but this
pattern's not going to work to get
something 100 meters down to a few
meters so the livermore engineers
wanting to make use of the work of dead
people or perhaps live origamists
said let's see if someone else is doing
this sort of thing so they
looked into the origami community we got
in touch with them and i started working
with them and we developed a pattern
together that scales to arbitrarily
large size but that allows any flat ring
or disc to fold down into a very neat
compact cylinder and they adopted that
for their first generation which was not
a hundred meters was a five meter but
this is a five meter telescope has about
a quarter mile focal length and it works
perfectly on its test range and it
indeed folds up into a neat little
bundle
now there is other origami in space
japan aerospace agency flew a solar sail
and you can see here that the sail
expands out and you can still see the
fold lines the problem that's being
solved here is something that needs to
be big and sheet like at its destination
but needs to be small for the journey
and that works whether you're going into
space or whether you're just going into
a body
and this example is the latter this is a
heart stint developed by zhong yu at
oxford university
it holds open a blocked artery when it
gets to its destination but it needs to
be much smaller for the trip there
through your blood vessels and this
stent folds down using an origami
pattern based on a model called the
water bomb base
airbag designers also have the problem
of getting flat sheets into a small
space and they want to do their design
by simulation so they need to figure out
how in a computer to flatten an airbag
and the algorithms that we developed to
do insects turned out to be the solution
for
airbags
to do their simulation and so they can
do
a simulation like this those are the
origami creases forming and now you can
see the airbag inflate and find out does
it work
and that
leads to a really
interesting idea
you know where did these things come
from
well
the hard stent
came from that little blow up box that
you might have learned in elementary
school it's the same pattern called the
water bomb base
the airbag flattening algorithm came
from all the developments of circle
packing and the mathematical theory that
was really developed just to create
insects things with legs
the thing is that this often happens in
math and the science when you get math
involved problems that you solve for
aesthetic value only just or to create
something beautiful
turn around and turn out to have an
application in the real world
and as weird and surprising as it may
sound
origami may someday even save a life
thanks
in the beginning was a screen
millions of us came together in a public
place
to understand the present
to see visions of the future
sharing emotions
sharing experiences
it shaped our lives
then there was a second screen
television
he connected us to our world
and even to other worlds
it gave us amazing new games to play
it made us think and got us talking
but although this is a world we could
all share
the experience itself was becoming
private
then came a third screen
it changed the way we worked and played
became part of something much bigger
the internet
and a revolution happened
we could play new games in new ways
find new music in new places
new communities new kinds of communities
emerged
but the experience had become individual
even solitary
the sense of community felt real
but it was virtual
and then
everything changed
[Music]
it changed forever
everything came to us in a device that
fit into our pocket
we went back out into the world
we listened to what we loved when we
liked
we played when we wanted where we chose
we shared what inspired us with everyone
we cared about
we carried our sense of purpose with us
we discovered new people and places and
experiences
and our sense of purpose kept growing
it was the end of something
it was the beginning
of everything
welcome
to the fourth screen